well in the midst of this crisis experts
are certainly back in vogue and the
government has put scientists at the
center of its response to coronavirus
cemaat report is the former chief
scientific adviser and in his new role
at UK research and innovation he's
leading the charge to find a vaccine to
the virus thank you very much for being
with us
morning much appreciated so just on the
vaccine how far away realistically are
we well vaccines are being developed at
a very fast rate and so there are a
number of candidates big companies small
companies universities all working the
challenge here is to make sure that the
vaccine is safe and that it works and
unfortunately that takes a period of
time to do so realistically it's very
unlikely that we're going to have a
vaccine for the present round of this
epidemic and you say it takes time I
mean are we talking we're talking we're
talking months but you're up - yeah yeah
up - thank you and in that case
obviously knowing how quickly this
spreads and most of us going to get
coronavirus
um over time it's quite likely that a
large percentage of populations around
the world will get it most of them very
mildly indeed and many indeed sub
clinically and if you'd like the
scientific information that's needed at
the moment is firstly how do we most
effectively reduce the transmission of
the disease because that's the best way
of controlling it and enabling new
treatments and vaccines you developed
that's the first thing the second thing
we need to understand the virus and its
effects to develop new treatments and of
course thirdly we need to keep society
functioning and so the scientific advice
the government is in all three of those
areas and there are trade-offs as you've
heard so if we want to look after
vulnerable elderly people they need
people to come and look after them if we
need the shops to keep going then we
need them to be supplied modern society
is a very complex system and we need
people to be able to work can you
explain a bit of the science behind the
government's approach because people
will be looking at what different
countries are doing around the world and
they won't understand why it is for
example that in Ireland schools are
shutting but schools and nurseries have
been kept open in here
in France in Italy they're closing bars
and restaurants and
okay well I mean the first principle is
how do you reduce transmission in the
most effective way and that is about
social distancing but the goal here is
also to look after the vulnerable who do
need care and also try and protect the
NHS from being overwhelmed and so the
idea is as sometimes described as
flattening the curve so if you have a
very steep peak then it means the system
is potentially become overwhelmed if by
distancing you can stir it down that's
the best thing to do now already the
scientific advice is to if you have an
infection or if you if you have symptoms
to self isolate so people who have fever
who have muscle aches who have dry cough
stay at home and that's one way of
reducing the spread of infection now I
mean you can go to a very extreme model
of this and try and shut everything down
but then society does stop working we
can have a quick look actually I think
we've got a bit of a graphic just trying
to illustrate some of this to show you
what different countries are doing you
can see that lots of sporting events
shot in the UK the cell phone isolation
as you were talking about then if you
compare it to say Italy in China
they've got ticks all the way along I
mean do you think we are going to see as
a months and weeks increase more for
example school closures and in the UK I
mean I think the answer is that of
course as the epidemic does potentially
gather pace then there will be more
limitations on people's movement schools
is an interesting problem actually it's
at the moment it's clear that young
people show very few signs of infection
they could spread they are still getting
infected there's no doubt about that but
it's not clear actually whether the
young are getting their infections from
the older or the older are getting their
infections from the young and that's one
of the important research questions and
it looks speaking to Matt Hancock was
pretty clear that perhaps the next stage
as a UK government's response is what
you were referring to is effectively
shielding so asking those most at-risk
groups over 70s perhaps those with
underlying health issues to self isolate
how important is that well the answer is
it will be important but
these things can't be done in absolute
sense because elderly people have to
have supplies of food they have to have
the necessary care and so it's not going
to be possible to completely shield
people sure people start doing it now I
mean lots of people be watching this
thinking I'm over the age of 70 or or my
mom or my dad is what's your advice well
I mean my job is actually to provide the
the scientific advice through funding
the research so in my previous job I was
doing the job that Patrick Thomas is
there doing and of course he's working
closely with Chris which is the CMO so
my job is really to provide the evidence
in terms of the advice I mean I think
it's it's very difficult to give general
advice it depends on the individual
situation many it is a junction school
and all of this is judgment calls and
one thing I would say is that the UK has
the most deeply embedded system of
scientific advice in emergencies I think
of any country in the world and so the
UK was prepared to provide good
scientific advice the government unlike
I'm afraid number other countries the on
the national risk register pandemic
infection has been the top risk for many
years you mentioned out the country said
do you think some of this has been
driven by politics rather than science
well inevitably there are judgments
about this so for example actually a
large outdoor gathering there are of
course risk but there are also risks
from 50 people in a are closed in a
closed environment if one of them is
infected so all of these things are a
judgement it's about how you do keep
society going in the most effective way
possible there's been lots of talk about
herd immunity yes we're effectively 60%
or more of the population gets infected
and then become immune to try and limit
the spread of the virus you've been told
it's not the government policy but you
know I think I think it really isn't the
government policy and I think this has
become the narrative has come a bit
confused has to be perfectly honest
what's going on is that the primary
concern is to save lives it is about
protecting the most vulnerable and it's
relieving pressure on the NHS now it is
perfectly true over time as more people
come infected and immune as a results
then they can no longer spread the
infection and of course the way that
vaccines work ultimately is by giving
her immunity in other words what happens
is when a large percentage of the
population is immune to a condition and
it is typically through vaccination then
the transmission reduces but I think
that this is not the narrative actually
the policy of the government the policy
is as I say to reduce the transmission
and save lives
you were you were very keen of course to
emphasize the science at the government
beyond what I can't work out is why
isn't government publishing I mean the
short answer is that I think that they
are about to publish all the evidence on
which the modeling is based
it would have been reassuring for many
people to have it from the start though
I I think that's true but I think one
has to recognize that if you like in the
heat of battle
what the researchers are really working
on is analyzing a flood of information
that's coming in very fast indeed and so
there are at least two independent
groups of modelers disease infectious
disease models that are advising the
government they're working very hard on
data that is emerging on a day-by-day
basis
but the government have agreed that this
should be published which i think is
absolutely right
should have been done earlier in your
view um the retrospective scope is an
infinitely powerful and at the end of
the day people will look back on this
and work out what was right and what
wasn't and it's worth saying that we are
also in UK research innovation working
very hard to create aid a Lai's source
of the scientific information that
people can go to if they want to find
out about a bit more of the details
about the science and what the virus is
how it transmits what potential new
therapies are and we'll be getting that
on and sometime in the next week and I'm
interested as well to know about what
you think the trajectory is what what is
gonna happen in the weeks ahead lots of
people will be feeling it's almost like
the calm before the storm and I mean how
far away is Italy from the peak I mean
the short answer is it's always easier
to predict the past in the future but
the answer is that this is a spending
infection it will continue to spread
there will
more cases UK and around the world even
in Italy there's still some distance
away from the peak I think that's right
and and the other thing to say is that
if you isolate everyone then it's it's a
bit like putting out a fire if you
deprive it from oxygen then the flames
will go down but if you have any embers
left in that fire the second the oxygen
comes back you'll get an outbreak again
and so it's this balance between trying
to smooth it or dampening it down with
the risk then that it will come back but
but the answer is that this infection
has a long way to go around the world
yet there's an awful lot we don't know
about it and that's why research is so
important and we and others the
government's committed already over 75
million pounds specifically for research
in the last few weeks and the other
thing to say is that we are prepared in
the sense that Medical Research Council
which is part of UK research innovation
has a center for global infectious
disease analysis which has been going
for years and the the the modelers who
advised here were very helpful around
Ebola Zika when I was the government
chief scientific advisors so these
aren't being plucked from thin air
there's a center for virus research in
University of Glasgow in Oxford there's
a human immunology unit which is working
on vaccines and so our research system
and if anyone wants a justification for
why fundamental research matters it's
this where we actually understand
viruses this is the first time ever in
history that within a few weeks of a new
virus coming out the sequence the whole
sequence of the virus was made available
and the Chinese release that some things
to be optimistic about despite the yes I
mean I mean you don't have to go very
many years ago and we'll we'd still be
struggling to work out what this virus
was realistically in some ways these
questions are always difficult cuz you
don't want to sound alarmist but I think
people do want to know the scale of the
the problem that we're talking about how
many deaths are we talking about
potentially is it is that is that too
difficult I think it's two different
drugs specifically because one of the
other important things
to know is that we don't know how many
cases are completely asymptomatic and
there is an important reason for that
because there are tests of two sorts so
the test that's being used at the moment
is a test to identify the virus genome
and so that will detect active infection
where there's virus present in swabs for
example and very briefly and will this
always be with us like seasonal flu um I
think it's very different to answer that
I mean coronaviruses have been around
and in fact there are they're about
seven corona viruses that infect humans
the early ones actually that were
discovered basically because called code
like in illnesses but then we've had
SARS which was in 2003 we've had we have
at the moment virus called MERS Middle
East respiratory syndrome which is a
very nasty the harassing that came at in
2012 and now we've got this one okay
thank you so much for coming on and
explaining some of the science behind
what we're seeing happen much
appreciated
thank you